[Music]  growing up in a religious town like ours  sins were dreaded even feared you and  your little posse are parading around  school calling yourselves the seven  deadly sins  from now on you will walk in the path of  the lord  once people started calling us the sins  everything changed  ladies it's time we take our sins  to the next level psalmist spirits  what's going on this is the devil chant  he wants to meet you he wants you to say  his name  aubrey miller she went missing last  night we're all in this together okay  satan trembles when he sees god face to  face  they are asking for trouble with that  [Music]  behavior  i'm going insane  we are so tired of being good little  girl  don't you want to be bad for once in  your life  [Music]  you